[Music]
how do you say you come here as much as
possible yeah a couple times a week
my newest time is photography I started
pursuing it two or three years ago but
it wasn't until about a year ago that
I've really decided to turn the camera
off of automatic and to learn how to
shoot manually you know and that
completely changed everything for me
it's like going from the microwave to
the wood fire you have to really cook
yeah what do you look for when you shoot
well I just look for anything that
catches my eye and that's how I love
about photography is it makes me pay so
much more attention you always have the
antenna and you see the beauty and
things differently you know and you see
beauty and simplicity to me that just
that's the way I look at cooking you
shoot on an analogue camera ya know it
looks like I mean this is this thing is
this is a beautiful piece of machinery
that would be something that would catch
my eye that's the the gradient of color
the progression of colors yeah and
shooting film is really hard I don't
even know what I'm doing with this pick
that yeah and I don't yeah push this
thing this way this thing there are two
arrows one goes this way one goes this
way and then there's a dot Yeah right so
you want the red dot right and so you
you mess with those numbers I'm like I'm
like I can't really see very well right
this which is why the oh no focus
cameras saved my life
I used to send the film away and they'd
come back and everything would be out of
focus gonna be like it looked good to me
[Music]
the guys who always amaze me or the
street photographers that's been my
favorite thing recently and being on a
18-19 city book tour I got up every
morning and the golden hour 6 a.m. and
just just shot each city just to capture
a place through through photography I've
been so so neat
[Music]
is this with you most of the time I'm
never without this thing everyone ever
ever ever ever it's always always